PROFESSOR: So many of you have
signed up this term.
As most of you know, this course
is now on an alternate
year basis, but it really
depends on how much interest
there is in it.
So this is certainly very
satisfactory interest.
This morning I'm just going to
go through the information
sheet logistics a little, tell
you a little bit about the
course, and then go through a
very rapid path through the
first three chapters.
So hang onto your seats.
But first of all,
the information.
One thing I did not mention in
the information sheet is that
due to the sponsorship of
OpenCourseWare and the
department, we are going to
have this class on TV or
videotaped for OCW in the
department archives.
And I hope that's OK
with everybody.
I think at some point we'll send
out a permission sheet.
Does anyone anticipate having
any problem with the camera
lingering on them or the back
of them from time to time?
I don't think this is going
to be an issue.
But if it is, either mention
it now or come
up and see me privately.
As I say, I think eventually
you'll have to
sign permission sheets.
Our cameraman is Tom White.
Let's give a hand to Tom.
And he promises to be as
unobtrusive as possible.
OK.
There are four handouts
this morning.
I hope you have them all.
First of all, the information
sheet.
Second, a little personal data
sheet that I ask you to each
fill out so we know who's
in the class and a
little bit about you.
The first problem set, which
is due a week from today.
In general, problem sets will
be due on Wednesdays and
handed out on Wednesdays.
And please do pass
them in on time.
We won't make any serious
attempt to grade them if they
don't come in on time.
I'll mention our philosophy
about problem
sets in a little while.
And then chapters one through
three, which are all sort of
warm-up chapters.
And problem set one is this kind
of warm-up exercises to
get you into context,
to get you into the
mood for this course.
It doesn't have to do --
well, it does.
But at this point, it's more
just getting up to speed with
the language and the
environment.
The teaching assistant
is Ashish Khisti.
Ashish, why don't you stand
up just so everybody
is sure to see you.
I'm delighted to have Ashish.
He was a superb student
this course.
Certainly understands
it very well.
Ashish will even be a
distinguished guest lecturer
for lectures two through four,
because I will be on vacation
during that time.
So you'll get to know
Ashish very well.
I think he will be able to
help you quite a bit.
His office hours we've
tentatively scheduled for
Tuesday from five to seven in
the basement area of Building
32, the Stata Center.
Is that going to be
OK with everybody?
Is there anybody who's --?
It's of course set that way
because the homeworks are due
on Wednesday.
That's all right?
All right.
We aim to please.
I've already mentioned
Tom White.
I want to mention that we've
tentatively scheduled the
midterm for Wednesday, March
16, which is the Wednesday
before MIT vacation week.
And normally I've run it for two
hours to try to minimize
time pressure.
For 9:30 class, that's easy.
We simply start it at nine.
But again, if anyone has any
personal problem with that,
please let me know.
You may not know
about that yet.
But I want to let you
know immediately.
Prerequisite.
I've held to the policy of
enforcing the prerequisite,
which is 6.450, rigorously.
Not so much because
the content is
really what's needed.
This course is entitled
Principles of Digital
Communications two.
But what it really is is a
course on coding, modern
coding, in a communications
wrapper.
Our motivation all along will
be how to get to capacity on
the additive white Gaussian
noise channel.
Within that story, we're going
to develop all the principal
classes of codes that
you would see
in any coding course.
But we're always going to be
measuring them by how well
they do on a particular
communications channel, the
canonical additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
But in fact, we're not going to
use very much of what you
had in 6.450.
The point of having taken 6.450
is simply to be up to a
certain level of speed and
sophistication in dealing with
rather mathematical concepts.
As you know, 450 is rather
mathematical.
Most of the Area 1 courses
are rather mathematical.
This one is rather
mathematical.
And if you simply aren't used
to making logical arguments
fairly quickly and in a snap,
you're going to have trouble
with this course.
So that's really the reason
for a prerequisite.
And I have found it's important
to enforce it,
because we always get, each
year, a couple of people who
probably shouldn't be here.
So is there anyone here
who hasn't taken a
version of 450 before?
Yes?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Mesrob.
I emailed you.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
So you emailed me --
Mesrob?
OK.
And you had taken a couple of
other very rigorous courses,
and so I'm happy with
your prerequisites.
The registrar told me that Mukul
Agarwal and Daniel Wang,
that's you, and Andrew Cross
have not had the
prerequisites.
Daniel?
What's the story?
AUDIENCE: I audited
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You audited 450?
OK.
Perhaps we could talk after
class about, in general, what
courses you've taken, and why
you think you can keep up it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Or just let me know how you
prefer to handle it.
We can do that immediately after
class in a corner of the
classroom, if you want.
And are the other
two people here?
Agarwal?
No?
Cross?
So they seem to have selected
themselves out.
All right.
Very good.
And everyone else here
has had 450.
All righty.
There's no text.
Unfortunately there's really
isn't any text that comes
close to covering all the
material we're going to cover.
Many of the individual chapters
in this course are
covered by various textbooks,
of course, in far greater
depth than I am able
to cover them here.
So partly what you're getting
from me is a selection of a
thread of what you really
need to know, at
least first time through.
And over the years, I've
developed course notes of my
own, which I'm now reasonably
satisfied with.
At least up through the last
chapters, where we'll spend a
little bit more time
this year.
And so I hope that that
will be satisfactory.
But I do give you some
supplementary texts in here,
and more are coming
out all the time.
And part of being a graduate
student is understanding where
to find supplementary material
if you need to.
So let me know if
you ever feel --
if you ever want to know, where
can I read more about
something, I'd be happy to
give you a suggestion.
Office hours I already
mentioned.
Problem sets.
They'll be weekly, except before
the exam and except in
the last week to the course.
The purpose of the problem
sets is for you to get
practice in getting
up to speed.
If you don't use them
that way, you're
not using them correctly.
I absolutely don't care if you
do them together or whatever
method is most effective
for you to learn.
These are intended
I don't recommend going in --
many of these of have been
offered in prior years, and the
answers are to be found
somewhere on the net or
in somebody's library.
But as you've heard in every
other class, I don't recommend
your going about
them that way.
Not much weight is put on
them in the grading.
The TA or the grader will simply
put a grade of zero,
one, or two.
We'll be happy to discuss any
of them where you feel you
didn't really get it, or don't
know how to get your arms
around a particular problem.
And in fact, I wouldn't put any
weight on the homeworks,
except that every year students
say, well, if you put
0% on the problem sets,
then we won't do them.
And so I put 15% on
the problem sets.
But in fact the problem
sets --
we do get an idea of how engaged
you are in the course
and how much you're getting
it from the problem sets.
That's important feedback, both
generally for the class
and individually for
each of you.
You know, there have been cases
where somebody is just
copying the problem set from the
previous year every week,
and then we can pretty well
predict that they'll bomb out
on the midterm, and they do.
So anyway.
You've been at MIT a while.
This is pretty much the standard
philosophy, I think,
at least in Area 1.
Any questions about
what I just said?
No?
The midterm.
Scheduled for two hours in the
Wednesday, the last class
before the vacation.
Counts for 1/3.
The final is scheduled
during finals week.
I don't have control
over that.
It will count for 1/2.
Basically, the grade comes from
adding up your scores on
those two things.
Doing a scatter chart and
trying to make some
intelligent guess.
Usually we get a little more
than half A's, a little less
than half B's.
But I don't have any fixed
number in mind for that.
It's really, I try to do it
based on how you do, using
pluses and minuses
for decoration.
And I don't know.
Again, I think it's like what
you see in every other course.
All right.
The topics.
What's going to be different
about 6.451 this year from
2003, which is the last
time it was offered
for previous years?
Not too much.
Basically, this course --
originally there was a
single course, which
covered 6.450 and 451.
It evolved, got split
into two courses.
And this course has pretty much
become a coding course.
So you are here because you're
interested in coding, in
particular for communications.
This is a good first course
in coding for, I
think, other interests.
Are you Andrew Cross?
Yes.
What is your situation
on the prerequisites?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's talk about
it afterwards.
Alright.
So as I said earlier, the
course is pretty much
stabilized at this point to be
a course on coding over the
additive white Gaussian
channel.
Those of you who are here with
other interests, that's not
the only place that coding
is used, I think will be
reasonably satisfied
with the course.
We're always putting it in a
communication context, but we
talk about all the major classes
of algebraic block
codes, convolutional codes,
tail-biting codes, capacity
approaching codes, low-density
parity-check codes, lattice
codes, trellis coded
modulation, if
you want to get ...
and all of their decoding
algorithms, which are just as
important as the codes
themselves.
So I hope that's what you're
after, is to get a view of
which codes have proved to be
most important over the years.
My context is communication,
but I believe you'll get
exposed to most of the things
you would need, regardless of
why you happen to be interested
in coding.
What is going to be different
this year is I'm going to be
rather ruthlessly chopping out
not perfectly essential topics
wherever I can through
the course.
And in particular, I'm going
to run through chapters one
through three today,
assuming that --
well, one is just
introduction.
Chapter two is basically how you
get from continuous time
to discrete time on additive
white Gaussian noise channels.
You did that fairly well in
6.450, so I assume all I need
to do is basically sketch
it for you.
And chapter three is proof of
the channel capacity formula,
which you may or may not have
encountered somewhere else.
But even if you haven't
encountered it, you're
probably reasonably willing
to take it on faith.
And so that allows us to get
immediately into chapter four
in the next lecture, where
Ashish will be starting to
work up from the smallest,
simplest little constellations
in Euclidean space, which is
where the story begins.
This hopefully will give us more
time at the end of the
course for more on what's been
happening in the last ten
years or so.
First of all, a much more
analytical treatment of
capacity approaching codes
than I've been able
to give in the past.
The real theory.
How do you design them?
How do they perform?
Some more details.
Enough so that you could go
ahead and implement them, I
believe, and analyze them,
and optimize them.
And that's, I think, really
important in this course.
Not just because that's the way
people are doing coding
these days, but also because
that's the end of the story.
After 50 years, we finally did
get to channel capacity, and
this was the way we got there.
In addition, if we really do
well, we'll be able to do at
least a week, maybe two weeks,
on codes for band limited
channels, where you need
to go beyond binary.
You need to send codes, at least
symbols, that have many
levels on them, not binary
levels, in order to send it at
high spec coefficiencies, many
bits per second per Hertz,
which is, of course, what you
want for most wireless or
wireline channels.
You are able to send lots of
bits per second per Hertz.
How do we do that?
Again, hopefully getting
to capacity.
And finally, I always offer the
teaser, and for at least
five years, I haven't been
able to get there.
We could talk about linear
Gaussian channels.
Where you get into equalization,
precoding.
Other topics that are
very important.
But I'm almost certain
we won't get there.
And in addition, this subject,
this kind of a scalar version
of what's done to a
fare-thee-well in the matrix
way, in the wireless course,
6.452, which is taught in the
next classroom in the next
hour and a half.
So I anticipate in future the
whole equalization of
precoding --
intellectually, it should
be merged with Wireless.
Because they do matrix versions
of all of that.
On the other hand, it forms a
part of this story, which is
just basically point-to-point
transmission over the additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
All right.
I very much encourage questions
and feedback, and
I'm always willing to be
distracted, tell stories,
respond to just what's
on your mind.
It's much more fun for me, and
probably helps you, too.
Does anybody have any questions
at this point, or
observations?
No?
All right.
We should just get into it.
OK.
So I say I always like to be
thinking of this from a
communications design
point of view.
We are engineers.
I am a communications engineer
and theorist.
And what's the design problem
that we're really trying to
solve in this course?
The design problem is
that somebody --
your boss, or the FCC, or
somebody -- gives you a
channel, which usually
involves some set of
frequencies and ...
over some physical medium
and says, OK.
I want you to design a
communications device, a
modem, to get as much digital
information over that channel
as you can.
So in chapter one, we talk about
a couple of channels
which have been very important
for the development of coding.
One, for instance, the
deep space channel.
The deep space channel --
what's the problem?
You have a highly power-limited
satellite way out there.
It's got a little
tiny antenna.
It can use whatever frequencies
it wants.
It's talking to a huge 140-foot
dish or whatever
somewhere in Pasadena
or somewhere
else around the world.
And that's basically
the channel.
And you can send any wave form
you'd like, subject, really,
to power limitation.
This is an extreme example of
a power-limited channel.
How do we characterize
such a channel?
Well, frequencies are
unlimited, but the
signal-to-noise ratio
is very poor.
You get a very tiny signal,
and you get noise in the
antenna front end, which they've
done everything they
can reduce it, they've cooled it
to a few degrees above zero
and so forth.
Nonetheless, the front end noise
-- in the very first
stages of amplification
are what is the noise.
And you've basically got to
transmit through that.
So you have a pure additive
white Gaussian noise channel,
which we we'll always write as
the output of the channel Y of
t is the input, X of t, plus
the noise, N of t.
Which is additive, independent
of the signal, and white.
The spectrum can be
taken to be flat.
All right.
And what else do we have?
We have that this has some
average power P, and this has
some noise power spectral
density which is characterized
by a parameter N_0, which
is basically the
noise power per Hertz.
Per positive frequently Hertz,
as it turns out, because these
things were all defined
back in the dark ages.
OK.
And we also, either because of
the channel specification or
because ultimately, we decide
to signal in a particular
bandwidth, we have a bandwidth
W. Again, that's just measured
over the positive frequencies.
So if it goes from zero to W,
that's a baseband channel.
If it goes from W_0
to W_0 plus W,
that's a passband channel.
But we're going to find out it
doesn't really matter where
the passband is, or
the baseband.
So those are three parameters
that specify an additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
And we can aggregate them into
a signal noise ratio.
A signal-to-noise ratio is the
ratio of a signal power to a
noise power.
In this case, the signal power,
by definition, is P.
The noise power, it's
N_0 per Hertz.
We're going across W Hertz.
So by the way we define N_0, the
signal-to-noise ratio is
just P over N_0 W. That's
the amount of noise
power in the band.
And there's an implicit
assumption here that only the
noise in the band concerns you,
and it's one of the key
results of 6.450 or equivalent
courses that out-of-band noise
is irrelevant, because you know
information about what's
in-band, so you may as
well filter it out.
And therefore we don't have to
count any noise power that's
outside the signal transmission
band or the
signal space, as we would say.
So two key things.
It's easier to keep in mind the
signal-to-noise ratio than
both P and N_0.
By an amplifier, you could scale
both P and N_0 so really
all you're interested in
is the ratio anyway.
So we have these two key
parameters for a additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
All right.
A more typical kind of design
problem is, say, a --
well, the telephone line modem,
which is something on
which I've spent a good
part of my career.
Your boss says, OK.
I want you to build me a modem
that sends as much data as
possible over telephone lines.
How would you approach
that problem?
OK?
This is your summer project .
What would you do on
the first day?
I really would like a little
feedback, folks.
Makes it so much more
fun for me.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can we just tell
him he's [INAUDIBLE]
frequency --
we have [INAUDIBLE]
frequency, so it's not like
this time it would
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
So you have in mind a certain
channel model.
How would you verify
that channel model?
AUDIENCE: Well, you put the
channel frequency response,
you could measure it somehow.
You could estimate it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You could take a sine wave
generator and run it across
the frequencies, and
see how much gets
through at the receiver.
And you could plot some kind of
a channel response, which
for a particular telephone
channel might go
something like that.
Turns out telephone channels are
designed so that they have
no transmission above 4
kilohertz, because you sample
them 8000 times a second
inside the network.
They're are also designed
to have no DC response.
So this might go from
-- this is --
well, I'm just drawing some
generic response.
And dB, I'll give you
my dB lecture later.
300 to 3800 Hertz might be
something like that.
And of course, if you measure
another channel, would it be
exactly the same?
No, but it might be
roughly the same.
I mean, all these channels
are engineered
to pass human voice.
Alright?
In particular, there are now
international standards that
say it's got to pass at least
between here and here with
pretty good fidelity.
All right.
So that's the first
thing you do.
You develop a model
of the channel.
And the key things about it,
first order are, it's nearly a
linear channel.
What you put in will
nearly come out.
It has a certain bandwidth,
which is somewhere between
2400, we used to say, way
back in the '60s.
Nowadays we might say we can
actually get through 3600,
3700 Hertz.
But that's what's the order of
the channel bandwidth is.
So we have W equals
3700 Hertz.
And then, of course,
we have some noise.
If we didn't have any noise, how
many bits per second could
we get through here?
Hello?
Infinite, right.
Send one number with
infinite precision.
And that would communicate
the entire file that
we wanted to send.
And so we have a signal-to-noise
ratio.
It's questionable whether the
noise is totally Gaussian.
You've heard a telephone
channel.
You know, it's some
weird stuff.
But this is what our kind
of normal telephone
channel would look like.
I should say, greater
than this.
Nowadays.
Used to be not nearly
as good...
Or I shouldn't say nowadays.
This was true about
ten years ago.
Nowadays everybody is using cell
phones, and these things
have all gotten terrible
again.
All right?
So please do not design your
modem for a cell phone.
Let's plug a nice wired
connection into the wall.
OK.
So that's a first gross
characterization of this channel.
What would you then do
on the second day
of your summer project?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's a good idea.
What do you have in mind in
designing a modulations key?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A signal
constellation.
All right.
What signal constellation
are you going to use?
PAM?
QAM?
Yeah?
What would control
your choice?
ISI might.
This channel doesn't have
a flat response.
We might --
let's say we've actually
developed a model where Y of t
is X of t going through a linear
filter, convolved with
some response h of
t plus N of t.
So what we transmit
gets filtered.
We add noise to it.
And that's what we see
at the output.
That's just a first
order model.
This is basically the way
modems were designed for
telephone channels for
many, many years.
Just with that simple model.
All right.
So if we have a filter here, we
might have to worry about
intersymbol interference.
But you're not quite back
at the basic level.
Let's suppose we decide that the
channel is reliable just
within some particular frequency
band w, and within
that band, it's more
or less flat.
All right?
When I talk about white Gaussian
noise, I'm always
going to mean that the channel,
the noise spectral
density, and the channel
response are flat within the
given bandwidth.
All right?
So I'm not going to have to
worry about ISI at this level.
Of course I will in my
telephone line modem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So even if we want
high speed, [INAUDIBLE]
so we want a rate that would be
greater than [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I suppose.
I mean, do you have enough
information to say?
AUDIENCE: Well, for example,
if we [INAUDIBLE]
64 kilobits per second, can we
travel 3,700 [INAUDIBLE] of
bandwidth that we need use the
bandwidth [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Is there any chance of
sending 64 kilobits
through this channel?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: There is?
How do you know that?
AUDIENCE: If you use
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: All right.
So that would be 32 level
complement --
that would be five bits per
Hertz, basically, talking in
terms of spectral efficiency.
Times even 4000 kilohertz,
that only gives you 20 --
AUDIENCE: Then a higher level.
PROFESSOR: Then a
higher level.
1024 level QAM.
But what's going to limit you?
I mean, why not make
it a million level?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The signal-to-noise
ratio, all right?
OK.
Well.
I suggest what you do on your
second day is you start
thinking about, on
the one hand,
simple modulation schemes.
And I would say 32 -bit
QAM is simple in the
context of this course.
It has no coding.
But just kind of give yourself a
baseline of what might work.
But another very good
thing to do is to
establish an upper limit.
Now, it's kind of amazing
that we can do this.
Up to 1948, no one would've
thought that it was a
reasonable to say, well, there's
a certain upper limit
on what we could ever transmit
through this channel.
The idea was if you transmitted
fast, you'd make a
lot of errors.
If you slowed down, you'd
make fewer errors.
And you know, there's no
hard and fast limit.
But of course, what Shannon
did was to show that for
mathematically well-specified
channels, of which this is
one, there is a certain limiting
data rate called the
channel capacity.
And what the capacity is for
an additive white Gaussian
noise channel, this is the
most famous formula in
information theory.
If we have time, I'll
derive it for you.
Otherwise I encourage
you to look it up.
The capacity of this channel is
entirely specified by these
two parameters, bandwidth and
signal-to-noise ratio.
And it's simply W times the
binary logarithm of one plus
SNR in bits per second.
All right?
And the Shannon proved
a strong capacity
theorem and a converse.
The capacity theorem says,
there does exist a
coding scheme --
perhaps involving QAM, perhaps
involving lots
of other stuff --
that can get you as close as you
want in rate, for any rate
less than capacity,
there exists a --
let's say a coding slash
modulation scheme, slash
modulation, slash detection,
slash decoding scheme --
such that the probability of
error is less than or equal to
epsilon, where epsilon can be
chosen as in any arbitrarily
small number.
All right?
So if you want a probability of
error of ten to the minus
five or ten to the minus ten,
however you measure it --
can't be zero.
Very big difference between zero
and ten to the minus ten.
But if you want probability of
error of less than ten to the
minus ten, then Shannon says
there exists a scheme that can
get there, as long as your
rate is less than this
capacity or Shannon limit.
All right.
So I suggest it would be a good
idea to calculate what
that is for this.
Now, signal-to-noise
ratio is 37 dB.
Then one plus SNR is about
the same as SNR.
Log2 of 37 dB, factor of
2 is 3 dB, so that's
about 12 and a third.
This is our first example of
why calculating in dB makes
things very easy.
So this is about 12 and a
third times whatever the
bandwidth is.
3700 Hertz, and we go through
that calculation, and we get
something over 4,2000
bits per second.
All right?
So you have no hope of going
more than 42000 bits per
second, if this is, in fact,
an accurate channel model.
I mean, I'm assuming that these
two numbers are correct.
If this turns out to
be 50 dB, then you
can go a little further.
All right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And it's really only true for a
perfectly flat channel that
satisfies the complete
mathematical definition of a
white Gaussian noise channel
within the band.
I'm shocked to find
that this is --
lots of people get through MIT
Communications course and
never see a proof
of this formula.
This is about as fundamental
as you get.
That's why I include
one in this course.
Or perhaps you've never even
seen the formula before.
Certainly don't understand where
it's valid and where
it's not valid.
OK.
So on the other hand, we might
try something like 32 QAM.
If we know something about that,
we make it so that it
fits in here.
We find that we can get
maybe five bits
per second per Hertz.
That's something called spectral
efficiency, which in
this course, we'll always
designate by rho.
So we can get maybe 3000 Hertz
without having to worry about
filtering too much.
So we're going to have a system
that sends 3000 QAM
symbols per second --
3000 two-dimensional signals
per second, each one
carrying five bits.
And so with that, we'll get
15000 bits per second.
So these kind of establish the
alpha and omega, the baseline
and the ultimate limit,
of what we could
do over this channel.
With a simple uncoded scheme, we
would check that we can, in
fact, get our desired error rate
at the signal-to-noise
ratio that we have here.
So we know, without sweating
hard, we could get 15000 bits
per second.
Shannon says we can get
42000 bits per second.
Maybe we want to put a little
coding in there.
How does Shannon say you could
get to this marvelous rate?
He says, well, what you need
to do is to choose a very,
very long code.
And if you choose it the right
way and decode it in the right
way, then I can prove to you
that your probability of error
will be very small.
Of course, Shannon's proof is
not constructive at all.
If you've ever seen it, it
involves just choosing a code
at random, decoding it
exhaustively by simply looking
at all the two the nr code
words, and finding which one
is closest to the received
signal, and
that's not very practical.
So there's nothing, in that
sense, practical about
Shannon's theorem.
But Shannon says, the way you
get there is you code.
What is coding?
Coding is introducing
constraints into your
transmission.
Uncoded is where you just send
an independent five bits in
every symbol.
And the next symbol is newly,
you choose it new.
So there's no dependencies
between the symbols.
It's just one shot
communication, again
and again and again.
Coding is introducing
constraints.
From Shannon, it's clear you
need to introduce constraints
over very, very long
sequences.
Basically what we do is we take
some alphabet of all the
sequences that we could possibly
send -- maybe the
alphabet is all 1024 QAM
sequences that we could
possibly send.
And then the code, by the code,
we say we weed out a lot
of those sequences.
So we only send a small subset
of all sequences that
we might have sent.
As a result, we make sure that
there is a big distance
between the sequences that
are actually in the code.
The fact that there's the much
bigger distance than there is
between the signal points
in any particular small
constellation means that if we
do truly exhaustive maximum
likelihood decoding, it's
extremely unlikely we'll
confuse one sequence
for another.
And therefore, we can get a very
low error probability.
And the whole course is about
the history of people's
efforts to realize what Shannon
said on the particular
channel that we're
talking about.
The additive white Gaussian
noise channel, which, as you
might imagine, is the
canonical channel.
But it's also proved to be a
very good model for things
like the deep space channel,
the telephone line channel.
In chapter one, I talk about
the history and you can get
some sense for the time flow.
And it really took until --
well, depending on how you count
it, up to about 1995 to
when people could get
effectively within tenths of a
dB of the Shannon limit
and you could say
the problem was cracked.
And research has continued
for a little --
the past ten years, and this has
been made more practical,
and they've spent more channels
refined in many, many
directions.
But really, you could say it was
a 50 year project to take
this existence theorem and make
it real in a practical
engineering sense.
And that's the story
of this course.
I think it's a terrific story.
So that's the way I like
to package the course.
How are we going to get to what
Shannon said we could do?
Alright, so that's
the whole story.
You having a problem
hearing me?
AUDIENCE: It's just the
noise in the system.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Well, it's probably not
an additive white
Gaussian noise channel.
One of the things about an
additive white Gaussian noise
channel is that there's
no dependence in it.
Time dependence in it.
So a third channel of very very
practical interest these
days is a wireless channel,
radio channel.
Let's imagine it's a single
user channel.
Everybody in this -- everything
in this course is
going to be single user,
point-to-point.
But nonetheless, the
FCC has said we
can have five Megahertz.
All right?
And we've got to stay within
that five Megahertz up to some
little slopover that won't
bother anybody.
And again, your design problem
could be, well, how do you
send as much data as possible
through a five megahertz
wireless channel?
If you take the Wireless course,
and I encourage you to
do that, or even if you listen
to the last couple of
lectures, I think, in 450, you
know that there's a big
difference in the wireless
channel and it's time-varying.
In particular, it has fading.
So sometimes it's good and
sometimes it's bad.
You have outages.
Not characteristic of the
telephone line and the deep
space channel.
So that introduces -- well --
a whole lot, many more
considerations.
I'm not going to talk about
that in this course.
For that course, it's held in
the next room immediately
following this one.
And I think it's an
excellent course.
OK.
So that's the story
of the course.
We're going to go from day one
knowing nothing about how to
signal through this channel,
except maybe we've taken some
course that's introduced to
us words like PAM and QAM.
And by the end of the course,
we're going to know how to go
at the Shannon limit.
And we're going to know a whole
lot of techniques at
that point.
We're going to know how to code,
we're going to know how
to decode at least some
representative examples, which
I've chosen to be the ones that
have been the most useful
in practice.
And they also tend to be the
most interesting in theory.
OK?
Is that clear?
OK.
Just an aside on the
first homework set.
As I said, these are just
supposed to be warm-up
exercises that should get you
comfortable with operating in
the additive white Gaussian
noise channel, which, at least
some discrete time, turns out
to be trying to code in
Euclidean space.
To encode and decode
in Euclidean space.
And the very first thing
I do here is to
give you my dB lecture.
Now, how many people here
would say they're
comfortable using dB?
Nobody.
OK.
Over the years, I've tried to
encourage Bob Gallager to talk
more about dB in 6.450.
And now I believe he does give
the dB lecture, but I don't
believe he gives it with
very much conviction.
I'm convinced the dB are a
very useful thing to know
about, and I think Bob had a bad
experience with dB early
in life is really what
the problem is.
Some army sergeant said somebody
was three dB taller
than somebody else, and he was
so revolted, he never wanted
to talk about dB again.
OK.
dB, which stands for decibel,
one tenth of a Bell --
the reason B is capitalized is
it is after somebody's name,
Alexander Graham Bell --
are very useful whenever you
want to use logarithms.
They basically are a system
of logarithms.
This gets all confused with ten
log ten and 20 log ten and
EE tests, but basically it's
just a very well-designed, for
humans, system of logarithms.
Think about it.
What would be the most
convenient system of
logarithms?
We're going to use this whenever
we have talking about
factors, or the multiplication
of a bunch of numbers.
First of all, you'd want to have
it be based on the base
ten number system, because
then it's --
you know, we have a decimal
system, and we want to be able
to very conveniently multiply
by ten, 100,
1000, and so forth.
So a very natural logarithm
to consider is
log to the base ten.
But so if we have log to the
base ten of some factor --
let's say log to the base
ten of 2 is 0.3010.
And in fact, you know there are
lots of tables that give
logs to base ten.
But it's just not so easy to
remember that the log of base
ten of 2 is 0.3.
Basically if we take the log to
the base ten of the whole
range from, say, one to
ten, that's really
all we have to know.
Because what we need is
one factor of ten.
This goes from zero to one.
OK.
What we'd really like to do is
to spread this out for human
factors engineering.
We'd like to take ten to the
base ten, which will now map
the range from one to ten
into a nice interval
from zero to ten.
That's very easy for people
to understand.
And ten to the log10 of 2
is 3.01 and so forth.
OK.
So if that's why we say a factor
of 2 is equal to 3 dB.
I find it's always helpful to
say "a factor of" when talking
about dB, just to remind
ourselves, we're always
talking about a multiplicative
factor.
So a factor of alpha is
10 log10 alpha dB.
Now most of you are
mathematically sophisticated
enough to know this is basically
the same thing as
saying log to the base ten to
the one-tenth of alpha.
So we're really using a base
here, which is ten to the
one-tenth point 1, which is
about 1.25 something or other.
So the number whose one dB,
which is beta to the one, is
about 1.25.
So we're just using a log to a
certain base, which is very
convenient.
The base is ten to
the one-tenth.
And that's all it
is, all right?
Beyond that it's not
very mysterious.
So I think it's very
useful just to
remember a little table.
alpha of one is how
much in dB?
It's zero.
Or I write it two ways.
Round numbers, or in any
system, it's that.
1.25 is about 1 dB.
2 is 3 dB.
Let's see.
3 is about 4.8 dB.
4 is what?
4 is just 2 squared, so
that has to be 6 dB.
5 is what?
5 is 10/2, so that
has to be --
ten down here is 10 dB.
That's exactly 10 dB.
And so 5 has to be 7 dB.
And 8 is 9 dB.
And that's consistent,
by the way.
You see then ten eighth,
which is 5/4, is
1.25, which is 1 dB.
And just, I find it useful
in everyday life.
Maybe that makes me an
engineering nerd.
But the first problem, for
instance, has to do with
compound interest.
If you just remember dB values
of things, you can do things
like compound interest
calculations in your head.
Or I gave you a more engineering
example over here.
If you want to evaluate log2
of 37 dB, it's very easy.
You just divide by 3.
All right?
So anyway.
I encourage you to memorize
this short table.
There's some more
things in it.
And use it day by day,
and become known
as a real MIT person.
Why schemes?
Well, why not?
All right.
The other problems on the
first homework set --
one's a quite algebraic
construction, using Hadamard
matrices of geometrical signal
sets, like biorthogonal NS
orthogonal and simplex
signal sets, with a
easy decoding algorithm.
And that's good to know about.
Next one is a QAM problem,
asking you to look at various
arrangements of signal points in
two dimensions, and try to
find the best ones for
various criteria.
The last one has to do with
spherical shaping of large
constellations, in many
dimensions, with high spectral
efficiency.
Many bits per second
per Hertz.
OK.
And that's chapter one.
Ok.
Chapter two we'll
do very quickly.
And then I could see we're
not going to get to
chapter three at all.
And that's fine.
You can read it.
Ashish, if you want to say a
word about chapter three next
time, that would be fine.
Chapter two is really about
given a continuous time
additive white Gaussian noise
channel, with model Y of t
equals X of t plus N of t, and
here we have a certain power
and we have a certain bandwidth
limitation W, the
same things we were using
before, here we have a certain
power spectral density N_0.
So there are the parameters
of the channel.
Or I've collapsed them into two
parameters, SNR and W. How
can we convert this to a
discrete time additive white
Gaussian noise channel, which
will be a channel
model like this --
a sequence of symbols Yk is
equal to a sequence of
transmitted symbols Xk plus a
sequence of noise symbols Nk.
Where again, this is going
to be IID Gaussian.
That's what "white" is
in discrete time.
Independent Identically
Distributed
Gaussian random variables.
This is going to have some
variance S_N, it's going to
have some power constraint
S_X.
We don't specifically see a
bandwidth in here, but the
bandwidth is essentially
how many
symbols we get per second.
And I think all of you should
have a sense that a bandwidth
of W translates, through the
sampling theorem, or through
PAM modulation, or something
else, is roughly equivalent in
discrete time to two W real
symbols per second, or to W
complex symbols per second.
Now the -- sorry, did
I screw you up?
Do I need to readjust?
All right.
Perfect.
There is a particular
way we can --
well.
So we're going to show that
these two, the continuous time
and the discrete
time channel --
if we have a continuous time
channel, we can get a discrete
time channel like that, where
the values of the parameters,
signal-to-noise ratio, for
instance, translate in a
natural way and that
they're the same.
And furthermore, where we carry
as much information on
the discrete time channel
as we do on a
continuous time channel.
So there's no loss of optimality
or generality in
doing this.
Now you've all, with a couple of
exceptions, taken 6.450, so
you know how to do this.
One way of doing this in a
fairly engineering sense is
orthonormal PAM --
Pulse Amplitude Modulation.
And you should know
how this goes.
We're going to take in a
sequence X, which I might
write out as a sequence of real
symbol levels Xk, perhaps
chosen from a PAM alphabet.
I'm not even going to specify.
And what do I need
to know here?
This is going to be at two W
symbols per second, real
symbols per second.
OK.
That's my transmitted sequence
that I want to get
to the other end.
PAM modulator --
so this is PAM modulator --
is specified by a certain
pulse response p of t.
and I'm going to require that
this be orthonormal in the
following sense.
That the inner product between
p of T minus kT and p of T
minus jT is equal to the
chronic or delta.
Delta kj.
So that the time shifts of this
single basic pulse by T,
where T equals one over two w,
the symbol interval, are going
to be orthogonal to each
other, and what's more,
orthonormal.
So in effect, I've got a signal
space consisting of all
the linear combinations of the
time shifts of p of T by
integer values of T, and I'm
going to send something that's
in that signal space simply by
amplitude modulating each one
that comes along.
All right.
So what I get out here is the
continuous time signal X of T,
sum of Xk p of T minus kT.
That's what the modulator
does.
Then the channel, continuous
time channel -- so this is
discrete time here.
Now I'm into continuous time.
The channel is going to add
white Gaussian noise N of T
with N_0 power spectral density
to give me channel
output Y of T is X
of T plus N of T.
And now I need a receiver to
get back to discrete time.
The receiver will simply be a
sampled matched filter, which
has many properties which
you should recall.
Physically what does
it look like?
We pass Y of T through p of
minus T. The matched filter's
turnaround in time.
What it's doing is performing
an inner product.
We then sample at T samples
per second.
Perfectly phased.
And as a result, we get out
some sequence y equal Yk.
And the purpose of this is so
that Yk is the inner product
of Y of t with p
of T minus kT.
And you should be aware that
this is a realization --
this is a correlator-type
inner product.
Correlate and sample
All right?
So what are some of the
properties that you developed
ad nauseum in 6.450?
First of all, if we take the
signal part of this, and we
have the sampler phasing right,
what do we get out for
the signal part of Yk?
We have X of T is this.
If we correlate that against,
let me say, p of T minus jT
for all j, we're going to get
zero for everything except for
the desired sample.
For the desired sample, we're
just going to get the desired
sample out.
So from this, we get Yk
is equal to Xk plus
the noise term, Nk.
In other words, there's no
intersymbol interference.
The noise term --
by taking these inner products,
what are these?
These are the coefficients of yK
in the signal space, under
-- these are an orthonormal
expansion of Y of T. Those
components which lie in
the signal space.
Can we ignore the components
that don't lie
in the signal space?
Yes.
If it's out of white Gaussian
noise by the theorem of
irrelevance or whatever
it was called.
There is no information about
the Xs contained in any part
of Y or T that is orthogonal
to the signal space, in the
orthogonal space.
So we simply take the parts that
are in the signal space.
And another property is that
this is white Gaussian noise.
Then Nk is simply an IID jointly
Gaussian sequence with
variance S_N equal to N_0 over
2 if the power of spectral
density here was N_0.
And one other property of I
should have mentioned here is
that again by the orthonormal
property, as you would think
intuitively, if we sent two W
symbols per second, and each
one is limited to power
S_X, then this will
have power 2 W S_X.
The powers are the same
in discrete time
and continuous time.
So what do I get?
Let me now show the SNR.
Let me compute it in discrete
time and in continuous time.
The SNR in discrete time is
2 W S_X over S_N, which
was N_0 over 2.
I'm not seeing the two's fall
in the right place.
What am I doing wrong?
So this is the power.
Discrete time and
signal-to-noise ratio is just
S_X over S_N.
Now S_X is P over 2W.
S_N is N_0 over 2.
Now I'm happy.
It's P over W N_0.
Continuous time is
p over W N_0.
OK.
The point is, the
signal-to-noise
ratio is the same.
In discrete time, talking about
bandwidth, the bandwidth
is really 2W symbols
per second.
So that's our measure of
bandwidth in discrete time.
And that is approximately
equal to W Hertz
in continuous time.
Now, I haven't proved that
to you yet, have I?
How to prove that we can
get a bandwidth as
small as W but no smaller.
Again, you've done this in
6.450, so I hope I can just
remind you.
If the shifts of p of T are
orthonormal, that says
something about p of T star p of
T, which is the correlation
of p of T with itself.
It means g of T has to be 1 to
equal 0, and it has to be 0 at
all other times, at all
other integer times.
Which means the Fourier
transform, power spectral
density of p of T, it has to
satisfy the Aliasing Theorem,
or the zero ISI, the Nyquist
criterion for zero ISI, which
basically means the alias
version of the power spectral
density of this has to add up
to a perfect brick wall
response between 1 over 2T minus
1 over 2T and 1 over 2T
in the frequency domain.
And there are simple ways
to make it do that.
Which is simply to have a
roll-off, a real frequency
response, with a roll-off that's
really sharp as you
like above 1 over 2T.
But so we can say the nominal
Nyquist bandwidth equals 1
over 2T, or T is 1 over 2W.
So it's W.
So the moral of this
is that we can
design orthonormal pulses.
If we have a similar interval of
T equals 1 over 2W, we can
design an orthonormal signal
set that satisfies this
condition for any bandwidth
that's not much greater than
W. All right?
And it's obvious from the
Aliasing theorem that we can't
do it if we try to choose some
bandwidth that's less than W.
So that's what justifies our
saying, if we are 2M symbols
per second, we're going to have
to use at least W Hertz
of bandwidth.
But we don't have to use very
much more than W Hertz of
bandwidth if we're using
orthonormal PAM as our
signaling scheme.
So we call this the
nominal bandwidth.
In real life, there will
be a little roll-off --
five percent, ten percent.
And that's a fudge factor in
going from discrete time to
continuous time.
But it's fair that we can get
as close to W as we like.
Certainly in the approaching
Shannon limit theoretically,
we would say that we can get as
close to W as we need to, I
should specify.
All right?
So there's one other parameter
that Ashish is going to be
talking a lot more about in
the next lectures which is
called spectral efficiency.
So far I haven't told you what
information the sequence of
symbols is carrying.
But let's suppose it's carrying
R bits per second.
All right?
We have a modem.
It's a 64000 bits per second
modem or whatever.
R is 64000.
Or whatever it is.
My objective is to make R as
high as possible subject to
the Shannon limit.
If I am sending R bits per
second across a channel which
is W Hertz Y, in continuous
time, I'm simply going to
define, I'm always going
to write this as rho.
And I'm going to write it simply
as a rate divided by
the bandwidth.
So my telephone line
case, for instance.
If I was sending 40000 bits
per second in 3700 Hertz
bandwidth, I'd be sending 12
bits per second per Hertz.
That's why we say that.
That's clearly a key thing.
How much data can I jam in?
We expect it to go linearly
with the bandwidth.
Rho is the measure of how much
data per unit of bandwidth.
What does that translate
into in discrete time?
Well, I'm dividing
up this rate into
2W symbols per second.
How many bits am I sending
per symbol?
I'm sending R over
2W per symbol.
So simply rho over two bits
per symbol, or since I'm
always going to think of
Euclidean space, I will often
write that as dimension--
rho over 2 bits per dimension.
All right.
Well that's not the exact
translation I like.
I'd like to talk in
terms of rho.
So here, rho can be evaluated
at the number of bits I'm
sending per two symbols,
or per two dimensions.
All right.
So for the discrete time system,
our major spectral
efficiency is just going to be
the number of bits I'm sending
every two dimensions.
It turns out if you get into
this game, you feel that two
dimensions are more
fundamental than one dimension.
Which may be a manifestation
of the fact that complex is
more fundamental than real.
Really we want to talk about
the amount of information
we're sending per a single
complex dimension, or we can
say two real dimensions.
Geometrically they amount
to the same thing.
Again, in the notes, there are
discussions about how you go
back and forth, and so forth.
So the bottom line here is
that we can talk about
spectral efficiency, which
is obviously a
continuous time concept.
But we can talk about it in
the discrete time domain.
And what it's going to mean
simply is the rate that we're
managing to send, by particular
scheme, if it's per
two dimensions.
For instance, 32 QAM has a
spectral efficiency of--
I didn't make myself
clear at all.
AUDIENCE: Five bits per two.
PROFESSOR: Five bits per two
dimensions, all right?
So that's the basic spectral
efficiency of a 32 PAM
modulation scheme.
2 PAM, plus or minus one.
What's the spectral efficiency
of that if it's for two
dimensions?
It's a trick question.
One bit per one dimension.
It's two bits per
two dimensions.
If it's 2 PAM, it's actually
the same thing as 4 QAM,
because 4 QAM is just
doing 2 PAM place in
two successive symbols.
So 2 PAM, you could send two
bits per two dimensions.
4 QAM is also two bits per
two dimensions Ok.
Similarly for any
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], we'll be
talking about codes which
cover many dimensions.
If you send R bits in N
dimensions, then the spectral
efficiency is going to be 2R
over N. So R over N in one
dimension, 2R over N
in two dimensions.
I guess initially, this
catches people up.
Because it's more difficult to
normalize for two dimensions
than for one dimension.
But come on, suck it up.
You're a graduate
student at MIT.
You can do it for
two dimensions.
And I assert that it really
is the more natural thing.
In particular, makes this nice
correspondence between
discrete and noncontinuous
time parameters.
So the SNR is the same.
The bandwidth has different
interpretations, but we're
talking with W in both cases.
Spectral efficiency, we can
measure it as either discrete
time or continuous time.
And oh, by the way.
What is the channel capacity
formula in terms of spectral
efficiency?
The channel capacity was
basically the data rate has to
be less than W log2
of one plus SNR.
Find an equivalent way.
So this is writing things in
terms of bits per second, or
equivalently rho, which is R
over W, has to be less than
log2 of one plus SNR.
This is in bits per
second per Hertz.
Or in discrete time, we have the
same formula, except this
becomes 50 bits per
two dimensions.
And so things have been
normalized so that now you
only have a single parameter
to worry about.
What special efficiencies
can you achieve?
It is purely a matter of
what SNR you have.
Telephone line channel 37 dB,
then you get spectral
efficiency of 12 and one-third
by Shannon.
OK.
So I'm sorry not to be able to
give you the very lovely
derivation of this formula as
a little bit of culture.
I encourage you to read
chapter three.
You will not be held responsible
for any of these
first three chapters.
They're all more or less
just for orientation.
Next time, Ashish will get
into the real stuff.
Any final questions?
OK.
See you in two weeks.